atheism is parasitic it can't survive
let alone Thrive without stealing
nutrients from other World Views and
this isn't according to me this is what
they say atheists now Define atheism as
an absence or a lack atheism is just the
absence or lack of belief in God so this
cordless drill is an atheist because it
lacks belief in God oh look everyone I
found another atheist this one's good at
math of course we can agree with
atheists on one thing their worldview is
definitely lacking unfortunately a mere
lack of something can't sustain a man or
a city or a culture if you lack food you
have nothing to eat if you lack shelter
you have nowhere to live if you lack a
child bride you're definitely not the
prophet Muhammad a lack of water can't
quench your thirst a lack of talent
won't make you the star of the talent
show a lack of Common Sense won't help
you to avoid dumb ideas so if atheism
has no positive content where are
atheists getting their beliefs and
values and rules they're getting their
beliefs and values and rules from
somewhere else this means that according
to atheists themselves atheism is an
ideological parasite sucking the beliefs
and values and rules out of other World
Views and here we found another thing we
can all agree on
atheism certainly does suck Christianity
was just swimming along like a mighty
shark through an ocean of civilizations
but the eyes of the shark are here
they're fixed looking out into the
beautiful and mysterious and sometimes
Dangerous Waters so it pays no attention
to the big dumb lampy clinging to its
belly the big dumb lampy obviously is
atheism the blood sucking parasite of
ideologies
now for all you atheists who heard what
I just said and are about to do your
best impressions of Thunder when he saw
that his master L pan had been defeated
in Big Trouble in Little
China I have two pieces of advice first
if you can't handle a little
constructive criticism maybe don't spend
the past 20 years posting Sky daddy Sky
daddy Sky daddy Sky daddy Sky daddy Sky
daddy sky daddy Sky daddy Sky daddy Sky
daddy oops that's exactly what you did
so too late to play victim now battle
has begun second since you love latching
on to other things to obtain your
nutriment how about latching onto a
comedian for a while and feeding on a
sense of humor for once to be fair we
all share this world and it's good that
when one group discovers something they
share it with others it's good that in
spite of our differences individuals
don't have to discover everything for
themselves groups don't have to figure
things out on their own each generation
learns new information and passes that
information on to the next Generation
language and writing and teaching allow
us to keep building not talking about
building some physical structure
although language and writing and
teaching help us do that too talking
about building an intellectual Cathedral
that we just keep adding to and
expanding more rooms more domes more
towers and spires this is one of the
best features of human beings so why
would I object to atheists stealing from
other World Views well the problem with
the devotees of parasitic atheism is
that they don't simply take what they
want from other World Views and then go
about their lives they do something much
worse than that after stealing beliefs
and values and rules from other World
Views atheists pretend to somehow be the
champions of the beliefs or values or
rules they stole and then they portray
the very people who gave them the
beliefs or values or rules as the
ultimate enemies of the beliefs or
values or rules take slavery for
instance for many thousands of years the
entire world thought that slavery was
perfectly normal they couldn't
comprehend a world without it Christians
were part of that world they were born
into it in the first century almost a
third of the Roman population were
slaves slaves the number of slaves might
be lower in other areas 10 or 20% of the
population or higher 40 or 50% or even
more slavery was part of the fabric of
society but something kept bothering
certain Christians about it so some of
them started freeing slaves and I don't
just mean their own slaves they would
buy other people's slaves and free them
slavery continued for centuries but
Christians eventually ended it in
Christian majority countries and they
were so successful in convincing people
it was wrong that Western governments
insisted that other nations abolish
slavery as well now ask an internet
atheist today who are the most
pro-slavery people of all time
Christians he'll reply and who are the
ultimate enemies of slavery the ultimate
champions of Human
Rights atheists of course
really which part of your la of belief
convinced you that it's morally wrong to
own another person and that we have a
moral obligation to oppose slavery let
me ask an atheist hey atheist I can own
a drill I can own a house I can own a
dog why can't I own another human
being I can translate that's drill for
we just know no you don't just know you
were raised in a society that taught you
all your life that slavery is wrong and
your Society taught you that because
Christians made it that way now since
slavery is a thing of the past in this
country tell me how does it feel getting
owned and then there's science good old
science let me ask an atheist no we want
to nerd this time who are the ultimate
enemies of science
Christians and who are the Supreme
champions of science
atheists there you have it comes from an
atheist calculator so you know it's
mathematically certain what's the
problem with the claims of our atheist
friends well in the past there were many
scientific developments over many
centuries and these developments
happened around the world
but the scientific revolution occurred
in a certain place at a certain time and
the people who were responsible for the
Scientific Revolution were all
Christians of one sort or another
Catholics Protestants an occasional
heretic but they all believed in God and
the Bible the pioneers of the Scientific
Revolution again all of whom were some
variety of Christian through their
discoveries in astronomy and physics and
chemistry and biology gave rise to
modern science
so who set the stage so that modern
atheists could be so into science
Christians did they did all the heavy
lifting and then they handed atheists
modern science on a platter and said
here's how it's done you're welcome to
join us atheists as always responded by
saying actually Christians this is ours
it's always been ours you Christians are
in the way in fact science needs to be
protected from you Christians because if
we don't protect science from Christians
Christians will destroy science that's
why everyone needs to become an atheist
it's the only way to save
science sound familiar that was the
rallying Cry of those gullible
narcissists we call the new atheists and
millions of people listened to the
lampre and became
atheists now we've had over two decades
of the new atheism tell me how has
science improved and flourished over the
past 20 years thanks to the new
atheists turns out it hasn't things have
gotten significantly worse for Science
and Jordan Peterson brought this up with
Richard Dawkins interestingly Dawkins
seemed to agree with some of what
Peterson was saying let's watch one of
the things that I've tried to study is
the preconditions for the scientific
Enterprise itself you you appeared to
agree with Alex that there might be um
presumptions axioms that need to be
accepted I don't want to put words in
your mouth because I want to get this
right before the Scientific Enterprise
can begin the preconditions for the
scientific Enterprise Jordan Peterson is
speaking at a somewhat scholarly level
I'll try to break this down a bit
scientific investigation takes a lot of
time a lot of effort sometimes a lot of
money go going back to the early days of
the Scientific Revolution if you're
going to try to figure out a law of
nature which is going to end up being
some neat little equation that's
something that might take years of your
life before you even Embark you already
have to believe certain things you have
to believe that the law of nature is
there waiting to be discovered in order
to believe that you have to believe that
you're in a universe that operates
according to laws you have to believe
that you're the kind of being that's
capable of figuring out the laws of
nature a mouse can't do it a gorilla
can't do it but you can you have to
believe that or you wouldn't bother
trying and you have to believe that
discovering the law is good that
understanding the universe is good these
are the kinds of beliefs that need to be
in place before science as a serious
Enterprise can get started I've tried to
think those truths let me lay out a
couple of them this is partly what I've
done while trying to make the case for
example that you're more of a Christian
than you think you are so for example
how perfect is the grin on Dawkins face
when Peterson says he's more of a
Christian than he thinks he is Dawkins
is thinking are you serious I don't
believe in God or the Virgin birth or
the resurrection or Heaven how am I more
of a Christian than I realize but
Peterson is referring to preconditions
of science that make way more sense with
Christianity as a foundation than they
do with atheism as a foundation and of
course since atheism is a mere lack as
our atheist friends assure us it
couldn't possibly be a foundation for
anything now for some of these
preconditions I think that the scient
scientific Enterprise is motivated by
the axima presumption that truth tends
towards a Unity I think that it's
predicated on the notion that there is a
l iCal order that's intrinsic to the
cosmos that that fundamental order is
good that it's intelligible to human
beings and
that discovering that order and aligning
oursel with it makes for life more
abundant I'm not sure exactly what he
means by truth tending towards a Unity
because there are multiple things in the
philosophy of science that have to do
with a Unity of science as an example of
what he might be referring to suppose I
drop this Dill
it's going to
fall see how did I know it would fall
well I've seen things fall a lot in my
life and I assume that the way things
have worked throughout my life is the
way things are going to work now there's
a Unity there this particular kind of
unity is called the uniformity of nature
but that's not something we really
discover it's something we take for
granted so maybe he means something like
this I can drop this calculator and it
will do the same thing the drill did
they're completely different things and
yet they follow the same neat little
equation I can go to the window and look
at the moon it's in orbit so it has a
different kind of motion than just
falling but why doesn't the moon fly off
into space oddly enough the exact same
law that causes the drill and the
calculator to fall keeps the Moon from
flying off into space
what seem like completely different
things are actually following the same
law so you look around and you see
endless diversity everything is
different from everything else and yet
there's an underlying Unity that you can
discover through science that's one kind
of unity that science tends towards
there are more the other preconditions
of science that Peterson mentioned were
that there's a logical order intrinsic
to the cosmos that this order order is
good that it's intelligible to human
beings intelligible means that it's
capable of being understood by a
rational agent and that discovering this
order and aligning ourselves with it
makes for life more
abundant but what does any of this have
to do with Richard Dawkins being more of
a Christian than he
realizes I think that the scientific
Enterprise is also predicated on the
idea that the truth will set you free
and I think all of those axioms are
relig and derived from the
judeo-christian tradition aha the
preconditions of science are all
religious ideas science tends towards a
Unity because one God creates and
sustains the universe the universe is
intelligible because it was created by a
rational being we're the kinds of things
that can understand the universe because
we were created in God's image and
understanding the universe is good
because when we learn about the laws of
the universe were learning about the
mind of God you can look through the
writings of the pioneers of the
Scientific Revolution these ideas are
all over the place and they're religious
ideas that need to be in place for
science to get off the ground where did
Richard Dawkins get ideas that in one
form or another are taken for granted in
science he didn't get them from atheism
atheism has no positive
content he ultimately got those ideas
from Christianity without realizing
where they came from and that's why
Dawkins is more of a Christian than he
realizes and if you don't believe that
you have to account for why science
emerged in Europe and nowhere else in
the entire history of humanity for
example and why it's also why it's under
assault from like all quarters now as
that underlying metaphysic disappears
like you don't have you haven't had to
be concerned with the mythological
substrate in your lifetime in some sense
because it was
intact three important things here first
Peterson says that if you don't think
the preconditions of science are ideas
that come from the judeo-christian
tradition then why did science take off
when a bunch of European Christians said
hey we've got these ideas if these ideas
are correct then we can actually figure
out the universe because it's made by a
rational agent and we're made In His
Image science didn't spring from these
ideas why did it arise among people who
had these ideas and put their ideas to
the test second Peterson points out that
as the religious ideas are being
attacked science is being attacked too
and Richard Dawkins is on the receiving
end of these attacks he can't talk about
gender as a biologist without being
attacked science has been demoted it's
now only useful when it serves the
latest whims of whatever group is
screaming the loudest in fact look at
what just happened from the telegraph
Richard Dawkins quits atheism foundation
for backing transgender
religion scientist accuses us group of
caving into hysterical squeals of cancel
culture Richard Dawkins has resigned
from an atheism Foundation over its
imposition of a new religion of
transgenderism Professor Dawkins The
evolutionary biologist and atheist
stepped down from the board of the
freedom from religion foundation ffrf on
Saturday after it censored an article
supporting the belief that gender is
biological Professor Dawkins accused the
group of caving to the hysterical
squeals of cancel culture after it
deleted the article from its website
saying it was a mistake to have
published it his resignation followed
that of two other scientists Jerry coin
and Steven Pinker who accused the
foundation of imposing an ideology with
the Dogma blasphemy and Heretics of a
religion the scientists resignations
come after the freedom from religion
foundation's free thought now website
published a piece last month by Kat
Grant entitled what is a woman which
argued that any attempt to Define
Womanhood on biological terms is in
inadequate and that a woman is whoever
she says she is so scientists are
leaving atheist organizations for being
anti-science and for forcing a new
religion on people I guess if we've
learned anything from science it's that
nature abhor a vacuum third Dawkins
agreed with Peterson on this let's see
that part again but extend it you
haven't had to be concerned with the
mythological substrate in your lifetime
in some sense because it was intact and
so the universities could flourish and
you had your freedom remarkable freedom
to pursue your scientific Enterprise
wherever you wanted and people lauded
you for it like that time is that time
is threatened and seriously so when
there was a large Christian majority
population atheists could complain about
Christians and Christians could complain
about atheists but atheists Like Richard
Dawkins were completely free to say
whatever they wanted now that the
population is changing and the ideas
that are the preconditions of science
are being cast aside science itself is
suddenly under attack and I think it's
partly because these metaphysical
assumptions have now become questionable
and that's part of the reason that I'm
attending to them it's not because I
don't admire the accuracy of quantum
prediction for example or celebrate what
musk is doing with his capability of
sending Rockets to Mars it's like more
power to the technological Enterprise
but you know what's happening in the
universities it's awful and Jordan
Peterson speaks from experience here
what happened when Peterson shared his
thoughts with our Brave New World the
College of psychologists of Ontario said
he has to go to re-education camp or he
can't practice psychology psychologists
evolutionary biologists they're finding
out that other people now decide what
they're allowed to say even about
science and that the people who decide
what they're allowed to say are again
whatever group screams the loudest so
are we getting closer to the scientific
Utopia that the new atheists were
looking forward to or is science
stripped of its foundations being forced
to bow to the whims of the mob and
that's that's not a scientific problem
it's under okay I agree about that okay
okay um I think it's an interesting
question why science emerged in Europe I
mean and I'm not enough of a historian
to know it is even possible that
Christianity did have something to do
with that and I I wouldn't categorically
deny that acknowledging that you don't
know and haven't studied enough to
comment is a good step forward we can
only hope that some of Dawkins followers
will learn something from this glimpse
of intellectual humility will they of
course not the Dawkins drones never
learn anything but that
doesn't in any
way increase my trust in the validity of
Christian propositions like the
Resurrection The Virgin birth and
miracles and Jesus is the son of God
perfectly fair point you can recognize
various accomplishments of Christians
and even believe that some Christian
ideas may have had a positive impact
without believing in Christianity as a
whole or in particular Christian
doctrines like the Virgin birth or the
resurrection Christianity may have had
some kind of
historical
uh facilitating effect that led to the
uh Renaissance that led to to the
Scientific Revolution and and that would
be a very interesting historical
analysis but it doesn't bear upon the
truth of the propositions of the
Christian religion it doesn't bear upon
the truth Tru of the propositions of the
Christian religion well some of the
propositions of the Christian religion
as Jordan Peterson pointed out are
religious ideas that are the
preconditions of science so some ideas
of Christianity have massive scientific
confirmation you can say well the fact
that Christianity got these ideas right
doesn't mean that they got other things
right and that's true but the ideas that
Christianity got right were derived from
Christian theology so I wouldn't say
that getting these big Ideas right has
no bearing on whether Christianity got
other ideas right I would say yes
getting certain ideas right doesn't mean
you got other things right but if
Christianity got these big Ideas right
you might want to take a closer look at
some of these other ideas because
they're all connected in
Christianity I would also say that since
the preconditions of science are
religious ideas and these ideas make
absolutely no Sense on a foundation of
atheism which again can't be a
foundation for anything maybe now would
be a good time for atheists to stop
pretending that they're the champions of
Science and that Christians are enemies
of science atheism didn't produce these
ideas atheism is parasitic it latched on
to Christianity became energized by
feeding on some brilliant ideas of
Christians and then attacked
Christianity
unfortunately as atheism was sucking the
blood out of Christianity it didn't
manage to absorb a single drop of
gratitude now if you're an atheist and
you're thinking well I've never acted
like atheists or the heroes and
guardians of Science and I'm quite
thankful to Christians or other people
who've helped improve the world
congratulations I'm not talking about
you I don't know any official statistics
here perhaps most atheists aren't like
the atheist aists who are constantly
bragging about being the saviors of
science and reason but I have to respond
to the people I hear from and sadly the
people I hear from tend to be the people
who can't stop running their mouths no
matter how little they know about
anything so let me say not to atheists
in general but specifically to the
perpetually hostile and narcissistic
atheists who are still running your
mouths about getting rid of Christianity
to pave the way for science even after
seeing millions of people become
atheists without benefiting science in
any noticeable way
whatsoever you guys are looking all
kinds of stupid right now you made
predictions about what would happen if
large numbers of people became
atheists none of your predictions were
right you were wrong about
everything your position has been
massively disconfirmed by reality which
means that if you continue pretending
that clearing Christianity out of the
way and winning converts to atheism will
somehow pave the way for a scientific
Utopia will have to regard you as the
Champions not of science but of pseudo
science
[Music]